what do you do starting from scratch
you're in London you've got nothing
you've got no contacts you're not in
your war room yeah and you need to make
10 000 pounds
I know I'm that guy that no matter what
happens to me I'll make it into a
positive yeah you can you talk about
being dumped in the middle of London in
your underwear and pulling it off I'm
the same you can dump me in the desert
by myself expecting me to dehydrate and
you'll end up seeing me on the High
Street in a Lambo next month to be like
how the [ __ ] did he yeah I'm that guy
he's that guy yeah so when they tried to
attack me with everything I kind of felt
excited I was like ah interesting the
game's getting fun again me and you had
a challenge let me ask you a question if
we had to make ten thousand pounds from
scratch drops in London who's gonna make
the 10 grand first that's a good
question I'm saying me yeah well you've
done it a few times I've never done it
before however you'd have to start with
selling something yeah you'd have to
start with becoming the middleman of
something and to start by taking a
commission that's the first thing you
could do I
do like the London dropped in the middle
of zero and doing it physically I'm not
sure I think no matter where I was
dropped I would turn to the internet no
matter what okay I think that because
the internet's just a global Marketplace
it's just so much better
I would
I'd find somebody with okay so let's add
nothing right I'd find somebody with
star power like you for example I come
along I drop you an email and say listen
I want to put something together I
believe I can help you sell more
I am hoping if I show you I can sell
more you'll give me x amount of
commission x amount percent I understand
you have star power you have something I
don't have you can talk in front of a
camera you can attract people you can
entertain people
uh what are you currently selling you're
selling this okay if if I bring x amount
of thousand people will I be able to get
this percent that's what I would do I
think that if if I didn't have the
ability to sit on a camera and entertain
I would find somebody who does and I
would be the blood and guts beneath the
show business interesting and that's the
easiest way to get rich in the world
today so you'd find someone that's got
an existing product or service correct
and then you would help them sell it and
promote it absolutely and early that's
that's the easiest way to get rich today
especially because commission only
nobody's afraid of saying yes to
nobody's afraid of being saying yes too
so let me see if I have my business
cards with me if I don't have I'm gonna
be a bit upset let me give you an
example of my business card because it
shows it perfectly so I do here we go so
here's my business card we'll just show
the camera keep keep this Bros for you
um but my business card
Tate Enterprise is unlimited kickboxing
world champion Master and Commander of
the War Room yeah also says on the back
my unmatched first Picasso a couple was
Shear into fatigability makes me a
feared opponent in any realm if you know
which is my saying it's a saying from my
father but it's basically saying
unmatched perspicasses the ability to
always pay attention perspicacy's
perception so unmatched I'm always
paying attention to everything all the
time and sheer into fatigue ability I
don't become tired makes me a feared
opponent any realm of human endeavor so
a man who always pays attention and
never gives up is a feared opponent no
matter what no matter what you're
fighting against him and then it says I
specialize in the following
wars fought assassinations plotted
Revolution started uprisings quelled
smuggling passport allocation
ventriloquist decentralized Finance
blockchain analysis whiskey Merchant
tiger taming it goes on and on and on if
you come to me with a billion dollars
and say put Rock on the Rock on Mars
I'll try yeah pay me okay maybe I'll
call Elon and give him 900 million to do
it maybe I'm just a middleman but I'm
the guy you can come to for anything I'm
that guy yeah no matter what you want
done I'll get it done I know a guy who
knows a guy
and I think that that kind of shows my
point overall if I had to start going to
do the same thing I'd meet people who
are extremely competent and extremely
good at what they do
you'll often find in life they're people
who are best at what they do aren't good
at the marketing and sales side of
things there are so many Fantastic
singers or [ __ ] uh painters or
whatever they're amazing and they don't
make any money they're crap it the main
the marketing the sales the whole for
moose of it yeah I'd do that it doesn't
matter if I find a singer and say look
I'm Gonna Get You bookings I want this
percent I'm gonna be the best bookings
bang I'm gonna put together a promo
video today I'm going to use my camera
guy boom I'm gonna make this excellent
and we're gonna get some personality
involved and you're gonna go up to some
random girl on the street and you're
gonna sing this is all the top of my
head you're going to some random girl on
the street and you're going to Boston or
sing to her and she's gonna we're gonna
get we're gonna do over and over again
even though a bunch of them will call
you weirdos to get one who looks like
she falls in love right there on the
spot and that's gonna go viral on Tick
Tock I'm gonna put that on your
Instagram account your Instagram
followers and when you're starting DMS
the Instagram account I'm gonna reply to
them I'm gonna book all the bookings on
the X amount percent but this all
[ __ ] okay now I got a singer out
there working I got a photographer out
there working we've got paint and paint
or she's out there painting [ __ ] bang
bang bang bang bang bang it's just a
game unless they get rich I think you do
well would you be down for a challenge
who can make the first 10 grand from
scratch cheat I can't I can't walk the
streets anymore maybe we can get a mask
design a mask when I walk the streets
it's I have to have full security teams
or the strap if I can find a way to
completely disguise you oh I don't know
that I'm top cheating on me bro your
accent would give it away yeah like yeah
like London's a bit of a weird one for
me because um
London's not safe anymore one and two
like like when I'm in Romania I'm armed
and I have a full security detail and
blah blah and when I'm in when I'm in
London it's unusual because
people recognize me and they they want
to some of them want to be friendly but
when I see full-grown people like
running up to me or coming up to me I
don't I've had a hard life right I don't
like when three full-grown men go hey
Tate I'm a golfer
I won't find you in this
position I've lost everything yeah
[Music]
yeah I mean all right yeah